in this video I want to talk about
tay-sachs disease which of course is a
sphingolipid OSIS I'm particularly going
to talk about the infantile onset form
there are juvenile and adult onset forms
but they are less severe I'm not going
to really talk about them here it's
worth noting that the tay-sachs disease
is more common in Ashkenazi Jews than it
is in individuals from other backgrounds
what's the deal with the disease it's an
autosomal recessive deficiency of beta
hexosaminidase a which is an enzyme
that's important especially as far as
its presence and lysosomes especially in
the central nervous system so what is
that enzyme do well we scroll down a
little bit here and look at the
pathophysiology this is all like the
breakdown of sphingolipids we had a hex
of salmon today say shows up right here
so it breaks gm2 bangla sides into gm3
ganglia sides by removing an acetyl
galactose amine it removes and it's look
like supposed to mean and if that enzyme
is deficient then this reaction won't be
happening or will be happening to a
lesser extent and what that's going to
cause is this these gm2 game decides to
accumulate and that's going to cause
problems
let's scroll back up here ok so that
beta hexosaminidase a removes an acetyl
galactose amine from GM 2 ganglia side
to give GM 3 ganglia side so one of the
key features is the accumulation of GM
to king this is pretty important there
okay because they're not gonna be broken
down you're missing the enzyme that
breaks them down and when they build up
they are toxic to the neurons that they
build up in and these features typically
present around 3 to 6 months of age so
the accumulation of those ganglia size
is important those GM to being the sides
as well as degeneration of the central
nervous system that is rapid and
progressive that's a huge deal here in
tay-sachs disease and so this can result
in a taxi of poor coordination infants
won't really be able to kind of like sit
up or turn OH
or even crawl properly that would be
cognitive impairment retardation
seizures fall are possible there's also
this idea of a startle response these
babies will be easily sort of startled
okay
you